geography is really a part of us and who
we are and how we see the world if he
didn't have a world as a child that I
learned very quickly that I had to study
maps if I wanted to get anywhere on time
one of my favorite features in Google
Earth is the historical imagery feature
which allows you to look at satellite
imagery back you know 5 10 15 20 years
ago you can see our changing environment
you can tour Mars or some tours of the
Spirit and Opportunity missions the NASA
Mars rovers
Sydney Australia good moon Illinois
the Olympics are a worldwide event that
everyone wants to participate in but
because it's in one place in the world
very few people actually get to go there
we actually had snowmobiles with our
street view cameras on them going down
some of the actual runs that the the
skiers would be going today unlike a
year ago you can actually go under an
ocean surface and look and see what
caverns and trenches you can explore
virtually see what the people are like
to see what type of food they eat to see
what the geographies like to see what
animals are there
there's so much to learn and explore
because you don't really understand
other cultures and other places until
you go there it's about understanding
the world around you
go out and explore and have courage and
you know go to new places
you